sorry mother
wrap the salmon okay well I'm good now
basically you're wrapping a parcel okay
now it's not gonna the Christmas tree
it's giving the oven salmon on there
yeah okay okay
egg what I'm doing now egg into the bowl
give that a little whisk and now we're
gonna do now is brush the outside of
this the season out to make sure that
you really stick that pastry the salmon
we drive the salmon generals with the
egg wash and this is the exciting part
okay come Patsy do it fast Manzo's risk
you getting excited
good oh just out of interest wine you
know she's outfit on tonight well it
worth to later
that's the pudding okay right okay how
many times we do web every time we can
wear at home now that's pretty short now
we've seen a bunch of that pastry inside
that help to get it really nice and
crispy now this okay is the exciting
part take you off are you really my rig
my instrument no no no yeah underneath
the pastry okay I just lift that up okay
now that's it lift up and then from
there I fold that over okay and seal it
there fold in the ends and tuck in the
ends is nice and tight don't worry if
the little hole don't panic cut off the
little flap side okay
egg wash the sides and now this is the
part where we got to turn the flaps onto
the sides it's fine don't let the little
hole
don't worry about a little clip that off
and put that up there now hey egg wash
on my side Joe trim off the flats yes
and then from there put the salmon onto
the tray good nice and carefully look
well then John oh that's good girl thank
you right where the flaps yes now there
you go start onto the tray